everyone welcome back to Westeros weekly
I'm ash crossing I'm Liana Galera we
have so much to talk about from C on
doping out of there to like a really
gross edit with a pie that was such a
big episode so much everything mattered
so much happen but it gotta warn you
guys right now Ashley and I are a little
delirious we got back from comic-con
really late last night but we did catch
up with a game of Thrones cast while we
were there we have a lot of special
surprises for you guys including an
update from sophie turner sounds of
stark herself yes let's kick things off
with the Nights Watch what we were most
excited about last week was a possible
reunion with Amira and Arya and it
happened it happened it did not go as
planned as planned so let's talk about
how she got there okay so Arya has a
little reunion with hot paw and not hot
pilots real good at potpie hop by hop by
hop hop I tells her that unbeknownst to
her Jon Snow has taken back Winterfell
and is now king of the north which means
that Arya has a home to return to which
she didn't have before she was obviously
on our way to King's Landing to kill
Cersei kill Thursday but now she kind of
has this like direction and purpose and
we see her leave and how to make the
decision to turn the opposite way and
head north and then when she's there
she's sitting by the fire she's trying
to get warm because winter is here she
then gets surrounded by a pack of wolves
and leading the pack is none other than
nightmare yeah
Nymeria but it's not it didn't go that
well no she was my Mary to come home
with her yeah there is like be her loyal
servant and I'm areas like girl I got my
own life now
yeah and what was interesting so after
the episode they do this inside the
episode where they kind of explained
what that moment was about and that
really was explained perfectly look at
that scene harkens back to season one we
last saw in the mirror when Arya made
her run away because she wanted to save
Numair his life she knew sir she was
going to kill her if she found her when
she finally finds the miry again or in
the mirror finds her and she of course
wants her to come back home with her and
be
her loyal companion again but numerius
founder our life that's not you is a
direct reference to what aria herself
said to her father when her father
painted this picture for her of the life
she could have as a lady of a castle and
marrying some Lord and wearing a nice
frilly dress that's not me
aria is not domesticated and it makes
total sense that her wolf wouldn't be
either and once the wolf locks away at
first she's heartbroken to have come
this close then she realizes that the
wolf is doing exactly what she would do
if she were that will I have a question
for you answer do you think that
interaction will change our design of
going back to Winterfell completely I
really feel like running into Nymeria
having that line and having that
realization like that's not you she's
going to realize that going back to
Winterfell is not necessarily her she
didn't want to be a lady of a castle she
wanted to kind of go after her own
things and what she wants to go up to
right now is killing Cersei yes so I
don't know thoughts beacon mercy getting
a new toy yeah sir she's got a little
giant ass crossbow she's trying to
convince all the Lords of the remaining
three kingdoms that she kind of has a
handle on gonna come with me let me help
you out like help me fight against Danny
and they're like [ __ ] she has three
dragons what are you going to do about
that so we see that they had this like
epic crossbow and I think it might
actually kill one of Danny's dragons
take a look at it in action
[Music]
oh I know we don't like that but it was
also a really awesome moment just the
score that starts playing I was like
whoo yes sir
which dragon you think is going to die
drogon I know I was like injured I know
and so I'm like everyone knows the mo
yeah hello my talk about impact exactly
well let's go back to Winterfell where I
may or may not eat on is also leaving
because he gets the letter from sam from
ty tyrion and fam okay and Sam's like
that multiple Ravens flying everywhere
so he's gotten yeah he's got the letter
from tyrion a letter from sam and he
wants to meet him got to take in the
he's got the letter from sam saying
there's dragonglass at Dragonstone so
he's like you know license to go a few
reasons to go to Dragutin I'm going and
I'm leaving santol stark young charged
more brother-sister squabbles though
like that when sunsik have like chiming
and I'm like hey chill do you think him
leaving her in charge was a good or bad
move for him I think it was really bad
because we know that little fingers just
constantly whispering in her ear mm-hmm
and even though we're starting to see
this on so I was like really she's
starting to shut little finger down
which is really great but I don't think
that he's going to go away once again
he's a cockroach but it was so good to
see Jon like really confront him about
it like he goes doors be Reds look
so to my sister that'll kill you myself
he deserved it he did I didn't like him
yeah I don't like the idea of sense of
being alone with him yeah but hopefully
that threat
she had works she has Brianne there
though and I feel like Diana is a really
loyal adviser and I feel like she
actually sees the book that Littlefinger
brings to signals and that epic fiery
battle out on the water oh my gosh
Greyjoy's versus Greyjoy's witch Greyjoy
were you rooting for
Yara I'm sitting on and beyond just oh
my gosh okay before you get to CN yeah
that was such a vicious battle we
haven't seen something like that since
the Battle of the bastards
urine is just straight-up savage I kind
of like it though I didn't like so
originally like when we were first
introduced to him he just kind of like
shoved his brother off a bridge and like
dick move dude but like here we can see
he can actually fight yeah he he
absolutely has her to take from it looks
like he's definitely has his gift for
Cersei here but he you know they take
out two of the sand snakes
yes we've won a one remaining pool area
they capture her they capture Yara
he has yara by the throat and he says to
see on like this is your moment like
stand up
rescue your sister and then Theon's
looking around seeing everyone getting
dismembered he starts getting this kind
of PS PTSD kashi flashback from his life
is reek and completely just reversed to
reek which I think shall we crown this
our iciest moment of the night oh oh my
Seon just nope sadder they're just like
hey sis I'm so sorry that our uncle's
about to kill you right now but I gotta
go but I kind of like that they revisit
the reek thing yeah it's it's totally
implausible for a Theon to just be Theon
and have no repercussions of all that
stuff that happened of course he's still
going to have like haunting memories of
the fact he was tortured for years right
and also Ramsay Bolton was one of the
most vicious people ever so you don't
just recover from that you're on my yeah
and I'm sure you're much loved Ramsay
you haven't incoming were he is a new
big bad of this year up so he took
Ramsay's place moving on we got to talk
about something else that was
little less vicious and a little more
sweet we got a little bit of a love
scene we haven't talked over those in a
while and they've been like
cliff-hanging for a while they really
have Ashlee caught up with Jacob
Anderson who plays grey worm when we
were at comic-con and she got the inside
scoop on how this hookup came to be yes
take a look when when things are getting
really bad I think it brings people
together and things are getting pretty
bad at the moment I'm sure it seems like
this season is going towards a showdown
between Cersei and Danny who do you
think will come out on top who are you
rooting for I'm rooting for Donny yeah
all the way even as you the actors even
as me Jacob
I'm totally rooting for Donny she's
worked for this he deserves this she
does deserve it yeah I look good cause I
think that was a first comic-con and he
was telling he's like I am living it
he's like I know this was like a lazy
cosplay but I'm having the best time but
we also it's nice to know that he
actually is rooting for Danny
yes Jacob is rooting for Danny um but
it's interesting because it almost
seemed like that scene between greater
Armand Assante was a good buy I really
and also it makes me really worried that
like he is going to die yes because
there's a balance a leader being sent to
Casterly Rock
yes I don't know if he's going to make
sure to kind of make it well that's my
thing is like he finally got to
absolutely with a lady but honestly I'm
just really worried because I feel like
whenever we have happy moments on Game
of Thrones to kill the people who were
excited to see because look we just met
Jacob on the press line he was awesome
we're like falling in love with this
actor exactly or so now of course
they're going to of course they're gonna
kill him I don't know I don't want them
to that he's over with Danny so why
don't we move on to keeping up with
Khaleesi anything up with Khaleesi love
you
[Music]
Danny was a very interesting combo with
more Darren she sure does she basically
calls the mountains like hey weren't you
serving for my dad didn't you betray him
didn't you also serve for King Baratheon
didn't you not do a good job so she
really called him out on the fact that
he's kind of a shady little guy mm-hmm
and that he uses his
the birds - really dethrone people on
the throne and she's like are you gonna
do this to me how do I know to trust you
and she says this truly epic line to him
after he's like no you can trust me I
promise like I choose you you are my
queen
and this is the threat that she gives
him and I swear she ever betray me I'll
burn you alive I would expect nothing
less from the mother of dragons hot take
Ashley a literally hot take I think
that's going to happen I think okay
here's my theory and I might just be
really tired but if you're a new where
they were in the sea okay
oh you mean okay do you think Varys
possibly had anything to do with the
reason that your underwear they were I
want to say no but also I don't know how
else he would have known who else could
have told them in that room or in or
maybe he's just that great of a see I
mean maybe but I found he has a lot of
little little fishies fishies fishies
that are telling him and yeah obviously
they're like oh that's like a big loud
yeah he could have found them but I just
it seems a little but also I don't know
that he would do that because he knows
that you're on wants to have Cersei keep
ruling because he wants to rule
side-by-side with her
Varys already does not like Cersei so
why would he help them more I don't know
why there's a lot of things that's true
okay I really enjoy his character though
he is a lot like Littlefinger and like I
should not like him but I do yeah I know
he's a good side of like the good side
of this is true this is very true um but
so Danny was planning her attack plan
she was really talking with Tyrion her
brilliant hand of the Queen and they
came up with a really great plan and it
was so epic to see all of those women in
Rome yes just plotting it out like and
it was really great because in that
other like behind the scenes sneak peek
of Game of Thrones they had said had
this been a scene where it was just four
men discussing a plan of attack
you would have just yawned it wouldn't
have been exciting but the fact that we
had four of those women really coming
together I thought it was amazing about
typing that comment I know
hahaha it's not just a show for boys
anymore well speaking of we are kind of
loving now I loved molester crushing it
yeah I see her kind of coming in hell
Danny to summons Jon Snow I also love to
shoes like heavily hinting like you're
going to want to meet him out of life
really loves him I kind of didn't
realize that Danny didn't know about
know of Jon Snow yeah but I did hearing
of him for the first time I did love
this bull Tyrion and Jon Snow in
separate conversations were like he's
cool she's good I got you I got you good
people good people good romance but so
it looks like John is going to be coming
we're going to be teasing that a little
bit later yeah none of that meetup is
coming quick quick quick quickly do you
think that Danny's actually going to
listen to the advice that Olenna Tyrell
gave her I think she should let's take
know if she will let's take a look at
what she said the Lords of Westeros a
sheep you she you're a dragon be attract
me a dragon he's a dragon a dragon - and
write on my tombstone I'm going to put
it on your tombstone I hope what coolest
for the growth you know I was going to
say I almost died last night because we
got that really gross transition from
who Sam taking like a great skills with
us hi Dora and then I went to the PI but
we got to talk about the fact why Sam is
doing that tiara very significant okay
so we know the jar is at the Citadel
he's been studied by the maesters to
hopefully cheer his greyscale because
Danny was like hey you can't come back
until you're Queen thank you yeah I'm so
[ __ ] so the maesters are like hey so fun
talk we don't want to touch you we don't
want to treat you you have six months
until your mind goes absolutely bonkers
but we're going to let you stay here for
one more day because your night okay
cool bye yes and then Fedora is
seemingly writing a letter to policia
yeah had a thing as bi you staring at us
Ortiz he's been alluding to fact that
he's gone boiling it in commit suicide
exact ice which brings us into the North
remembers so there's a reason that Sam
is so keen on helping Jorah and that's
because jerez father was the
a commander of the night's watch when
Sam first join G or Mormont who had
saved fan previous exactly it was
actually a such a sweet throwback moment
to let us take a look as to why Sam
cares so much I think so because we may
as well just go healthy enough
Darley I forbid you to die do you hear
me why should the rest of us gone rust
feel responsible for what am I supposed
to do make sure he gives back alive if
he doesn't you don't owe the smell sound
quite familiar because a very similar
line was lettered last night by Sam's so
let's take a look at exactly what he
said he was on to him today so Jorah
I love the parallel yeah it was so sweet
he makes so much sense it makes so much
time although that was all the way back
from from season 3 so that's why I
definitely needed a little bit of a
refresher right absolutely yeah
oh my goodness alright wait are we
listen I'm getting oh sorry we're
getting a special Stark sister update
and it's from sophie turner herself
I know so we caught up with sophie
turner this weekend at Comic Con we told
her all about the Stark's sister update
and here's what she had to say we have a
brand new game of Thrones after show
called Westeros weekly and we have a
running segment called the Stark's
sister update no.1 where each week we
give an update have they seen each other
and then we just say no no that's
amazing I like that can you give us a
Stark sister update no this is the
specific I mean it would be amazing if
they were to cross over at some point
but I think we have more chance in the
Marvel Universe in Game of Thrones it's
a lot about happy endings on gamers go
Sophie obviously knows not to give
spoilers but that also kind of reaffirms
that area that's Aria of not going to
serve oh thanks
I loved what she said though that we
could get across over in the Marvel
Universe because you know maybe just
join x-men New Mutants and she's already
in the x-men franchise that ready
amazing yeah but I still think that
we're going to get them together one day
even below hope I don't know I hope so
for ever or I don't know I just kind of
doing a hot take right now just because
we're right then I can be like haha see
if I'm wrong everyone can beat me up so
where do we stand right now in the race
to the Iron Throne let's check it out
okay so definitely we still had surfing
in the lead because she's still actually
sitting on the throne and then Danny
really moved up this week because you
know she really put her plan into action
but yeah back her up a little bit a Mac
and move up move up Stark's a little bit
because John is actually on his way to
Dragonstone which it means he's actually
leaving the north and doing something
about it put some men pairing up
together can you have an even further
that's true we'll check back now y'all
got a day you're on like near near
Lannister or like I feel like maybe
he'll just like hold on to the tail
because he's really just riding on to
Cersei Skrtel you the new boy he's
proven his stuff though cuz we saw line
going on in the teaser fernack we we did
let's take a look at that and break it
down born to rule the Seven Kingdoms and
I will
we've already begun I'm drawn first
blood first it will be ready they know
we're coming
is happening is happening what were you
taking away from that I really think
that John and Danny are gonna be feeling
each other you think I don't know at
least a little man just first little
anti actions respecting each other
because we've been wanting these
characters to meet for the longest time
and it looks like next week it's finally
going to happen
but what I'm worried about is that we've
been wanting them together to finally
meet face to face what if they hate each
other
Danny's kind of taken this turn I should
notice she in the way her way of
speaking it's illegal she's much more
regal and I'm nervous that I don't think
she's going to turn into any kind of mad
I mean but she is
I do wearing herself different I want
them to actually talk about that though
I would like to see her kind of like dip
into that and then have cheering be like
you're not your father's daughter right
like please rein it in they are meeting
next week we saw your on yeah happily
coming became planning wishes people are
cheering for her yes like could she be
the the king's people because the people
that came it sounds like he's about to
be a king possibly marriage to serve
because he's got a couple of gifts that
she would really like because here's a
question minors murder here's a little
bit of a throwback
remember when Cersei kept the shame
shame girl and she's still probably in
the dungeon being tortured by the
mountain yes do you think she's going to
put the Doran Queen into there as well
oh maybe yeah but also you know I don't
want a roof I'm not rooting for Cersei
on the Iron Throne oh no but the fact
that they killed Marcella I'm kind of
rooting for Cersei in this little image
in this one like you can torture just
this girl yes we're okay with that you
get a free pass sirs-e because she
killed your daughter and then we see the
unsullied taking Casterly Rock yesh
could mean the end of great work great
well I hope not
I really hope no that's my prediction I
don't want to see you think that he got
his happiness so in the immediate next
episode he's going to die I think that
it's going to be he got his happiness in
this next episode she's going to be
incredibly badass and then the episode
after that he's gonna die but that would
be a nice arc don't even yeah yeah yeah
okay Oh
you like to talk about next week
obviously lots to talk about this week -
we thank you guys for sticking through
with our like post Comic Con babbles
what did I even say you do have a lot of
Game of Thrones interviews though so
look over those or a neater line will
also we'll have those coming up in the
next few episodes as well we also have
so many amazing Comic Con videos on et's
YouTube page so be sure to subscribe to
the channel like comment all those great
things tweet us if you want if you want
yeah sure thank you guys so much for
watching watch those weekly I'm Liana
Galera I'm Ashley cross and we will see
you next week